People at the expo in the wonderful city, Udacity, love Grant's glasses wipers,
but they're also really looking forward to his nozzles coming out. In order to
ensure the success of his business, Grant wants to move into nozzle
manufacturing really soon but nozzles, which if you remember, are the things
that spray cleaning solution onto the glasses They're a little bit harder to
make than glasses wipers. He's going to need to buy new machinery in order to
start manufacturing them. On top of having to purchase this new machinery, Grant
will also have to pay for the materials that are required to make a single
nozzle. These cost about $2 per nozzle. As always, Grant's on a pretty tight
budget and he'd like our help to figure out how much he should plan to spend on
this new nozzle making machinery.